رئيس الشركه المطوره لتشات جي بي تي اس
ضمن العالم نعم الذكاء الاصطناعي ممكن يضر
العالم ووزير التربيه يفتح تحقيق عاجل في
فيديو اغضب العراقيين لمدرس يوهين طالباته
والفنان المصري غاده والي ترد في تفاعلكم
على اتهام فنان روسي لها بسرقه اعماله
للمره الثانيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
الذكاء الاصطناعي الفتره الماضيه شغل
العالم الشاغل خاصه من بعض ظهور تشاد
وتحول لي التطبيق الاكثر نموا في العالم
في ناس جالسه تستعملوا وتشكر فيه اناس
بتستعمله بس بتقول انه الموضوع يخوف وفي
فريق خايف جدا ومرعوب وبيحذروا من انه قال
الاء هذه حتسيطر علينا لكن على الناحيه
الثانيه في ناس كمان مختصه بتطمن الجميع
وبتقول ما في شيء من هذا الكلام اخرهم حتى
من كم يوم ضيفنا مختص في التكنولوجيا لكن
امس الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه اوبن اي اي
المطوره
طلع في تصريح امام مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
صدم العالم تماما
مثل ما سمعتوا رئيس الشركه المطوره
انه اسوا مخافه انه الذكاء الاصطناعي يضر
العالم وطبعه الناس وطبعا يعني الناس مسكت
التصريح وقالت انه شهد شاهد من اهلها
شفتوا انه لازم نخاف اهو الرجال نفسه رئيس
الشركه بيقول كذا وعلى فكره تطور الذكاء
الاصطناعي السريع مؤخرا اوريدي عامل حاله
خوف ورعب في العالم ناقشناها بتفاعلكم من
قبل وحتى في استطلاعات بتتكلم انه اكثر من
نص الناس خايفين على مستقبل البشريه بسبب
الذكاء الاصطناعي واليوم رجع هذا الكلام
والخوف اتجدد وزاد الطين بله طبعا مصدر
التصريح احنا بتفاعلكم كمان حبينا نعرف
رايكم وسالناكم على تويتر لو بعد التصريح
الصادم هذا انتم شايفين ان المستقبل
البشريه في خطر بسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي
واجابتكم جاءت كالتعني
الاغلبيه يبدو من الخايفين لانه 21 بالميه
فقط قالوا لا بينما اكثر من 78% منكم
شايفين انه نعم مستقبل البشريه في خطر
بسبب او الذكاء الاصطناعي السؤال هنا هل
فعليا في اهميه لفكره انه التصريح هذا
طالع من رئيس الشركه نفسه هل الان لازم
نخاف ونطالب بالسيطره على الموضوع خلونا
نناقش الموضوع مع ضيفنا المفضل فيما يخص
مواضيع التكنولوجيا بشكل عام والذكاء
الاصطناعي خصوصا من الكويت دكتور محمد
قاسم عضو مجلس اداره المدرسه الرقميه
والاستاذ السابق في الدراسات التكنولوجيه
اهلا فيك معنا دكتور انا عارفه انك انت
حابب تطلع الفضاء وكل الكلام هذا كله بس
انت يبدو لي كانك الان اوريدي في المركبه
الفضائيه الخلفيه اللي وراك انت فين جالس
احنا خلاص الحين وصلنا الى مرحله جديده في
في التصوير نعم
هذه والله يعني
رهيبه هذه جديده طيب مبروك انا قاعد
استخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي علشان يشيل
الخلفيه اللي حوالي خلفي يعني وحاط بدالها
صوره
باستخدام شيء مسويته فهذه واحده من
الايجابيات الذكاء الاصطناعي جميل جدا طيب
لكن الان لما نسمع انه واحد من المطورين
ورئيس شركه اللي هي اوبن اي هاي عملت شات
جي بي تي بيقول انه يعني في احتمال ايه
وضرر كبير للبشريه يعني تصريح اكيد صادم
لازم يكون
طبعا بالدرجه الاولى لازم نسمع الكلام
اللي دار في مجلس الشيوخ نفسه يعني كان
يمكن على قمه الاولويات عندهم ان
الانتخابات ما تتضرر لان احنا نعرف في
السابق يعني اثرت على الانتخابات بشكل
كبير بس تخيلي الان عندنا ذكاء اصطناعي
يتدخل في الانتخابات
ويوصل رسائل موجهه لكل شخص يعني انا اذا
اتفاعل مع الذكاء الاصطناعي والمعلومات
هذه ياخذونها عني انا ولو كنت انا في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وراح انتخب
اللي راح يصير ايش ان الذكاء الاصطناعي
يوجه لي رساله لانه يعرف طبيعتي شلون
صايره يوجه لي اياها بطريقه انسانيه يعني
ساره احنا عندنا مشكله كبيره الانسان
يتاثر يعني يعيش بالكلام ويموت بالكلام
يعيش بلغه ويموت في اللغه نتاثر بسرعه
ولذلك الانتخابات تاثر فهذا واحد اثنين
عندنا اشكاليه ثانيه اللي هي الوظائف
الوظائف ممكن تتاثر
وخليني اعطيك مثال في موقع من المواقع من
غير ذكر اسمه حتى اعمل لها دعايه لكن هذا
الموقع تستطيعين ان تدخلي داخل وتقولين
انا اريد شخص في المحاسبه شخص في مثلا
الماركتينج شخص يعطيني المحاماه وكل هؤلاء
الاشخاص هم ذكاء اصطناعي
وبرخص التراب يعني الذكاء الاصطناعي حيلغي
وظائف
هذا الشيء اللي احنا ما نتمنى انه يصير
ولذلك قاعدين يحولون يفكرون كيف نضع لوائح
لهذا الموضوع حتى نضمن ان الوظائف ما تروح
طبعا لا ننسى هناك وظائف جديده ستتكون
بسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي لكن نريد موازنه لا
نريد ان نفقد الوظائف اخرى
لما بتتكلم على موضوع الانتخابات صحيح
والوظائف صحيح بس هدول النقطتين تحديدا
كمان نتكلم عنهم سام اللي هو رئيس الشركه
ومع ذلك وقال انه قد او انه حتلغي وظائف
وتظهر وظائف جديده ومع ذلك قال انه ستضر
العالم
بالضبط شوفي الحين الضرر الاساسي من شيء
مثل
هو تاثيره في
انتاج ماده فيها اشاعات فيها اضطرابات
فيها تاثير نحن نتاثر بالكلمه بسرعه فلذلك
ممكن دول تستغل هذه الفكره في انها توجه
رسائل للناس والشعوب رسائل مزيفه الشعوب
للتاثير عليها حتى تسقط مثلا حكوماتها حتى
تغير من اشياء معينه في نظام عملها فلذلك
هذا يعني هذا يعتبر واحد من مخاوف
الرئيسيه خصوصا يعني نحن نعرف الان الصراع
موجود بين الدول الكبرى وهذا راح ياثر
اكيد شغالين على هذا الموضوع بشكل جاد
حاليا طيب بس الان لما هو بيقول انه بيحذر
من هذا الموضوع
وبطالب الكونجرس كمان انه يتم وضع قيود او
محاذير او اليه للتعامل مع هذا الموضوع
والكونجرس بدوره كان بيقولوا احنا تاخرنا
في موضوع مواقع التواصل خلينا نلحق الذكاء
الاصطناعي قبل ما نتاخر فيه يعني
واقعيا احنا شفنا موضوع اللي صار في
التواصل الاجتماعي واقعيا هل يمكن اصلا
وضع قيود للسيطره على الذكاء الاصطناعي
السؤال انا اعتقد هذا يمكن اهم سؤال لان
فعليا
الذكاء الاصطناعي الان يخرج لجميع الناس
والكثير من الناس تقدر تستخدمه يعني ليس
مثل انه يكون عندنا نووي اللي ما حد يقدر
يصنعه بسهوله او مثلا السلاح البيولوجي
اللي تحتاجين الى معامل لصناعته
مثلا يحتاج الى كمبيوترات كبيره لكن حتى
اصنع ذكاء اصطناعي بسيط هو في متناول يد
الجميع اليوم تدخلين على النت تقدرين
تاخذين الذكاء الاصطناعي تحطينه على
الكمبيوتر الشخصي
وتفعلينه وتسوين منه مسجات فالسيطره اعتقد
امر صعب لكن لا ننسى ان الفكر الاساسي
للذكاء الاصطناعي وتطويره وخصوصا الذكاء
الاعقد اللي هو او الاكثر تعقيدا اللي هو
الذكاء العامل الصناعي هذا لا يزال بيد
الشركات وبيد الجهات المؤس هي اللي فيها
ابحاث علميه وتحتاج الى عقول قويه جدا
فايضا لا يزال هناك مجال للتحكم في هذا
الجانب بحيث ان اذا اي شركه تمادت او
اخرجت ذكاء الاصطناعي ما في سيطره تضع
عليها قيود وتضع عليها شروط او توقف عملها
بحيث انها ما تستطيع ان تستمر في مثل هذا
العمل بس مره اخرى اؤكد ان انا لا اظن
شخصيا ان الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن السيطره
عليه لان الان خرج من الفانوس وهو الان
موجود بايدي الكثير من الناس يعني هو
بيختلفوا معك بعض الناس وتحديدا يمكن في
الف شخصيه بارزه كمان وقعوا رساله اذا
تذكر يعني دكتور من ضمنهم ماسك بيطالبوا
فيها
بوقف تطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي حتى يتم وضع
المحاذير والكلام هذا كله بس ما اعرف صحيح
يعني بما انك يعني كلامك اللي هو قلته انه
يعني فعلا اصبح مفتوح للجميع بامكان
الجميع تطويره حاليا
فخلص اعتقد المارد خرج
بالضبط
خلينا نقول نريد ان نوازل الامور نريد ان
نضع اللوائح نريد ان نضبط الموضوع ولكن لا
نخف الى هذه الدرجه بحيث انه لا نستطيع ان
نعمل لا نستطيع ان نطور
المواقع التواصل يعني في لها اضرار لكن
استفدنا منها استفاده ايضا كبيره في
حياتنا طيب نحن بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كان معنا من الكويت دكتور محمد قاسم عضو
مجلس اداره المدرسه الرقميه والاستاذ
السابق في كليه الدراسات التكنولوجيه شكرا
لك
طيب تصريح اخر مثير لرئيس الاوبن اي امس
كان عن الانتخابات وتحديدا تطرقنا له في
نقاشنا مع دكتور محمد قاسم وكمان لو
فاكرين من كم يوم العالم كان اصلا قامت
الدنيا كده على تقارير عن قدره الذكاء
الصناعي على التاثير على الانتخابات امس
امام مجلس الشيوخ
التمان قال انه موضوع تاثير الذكاء
الاصطناعي على الانتخابات مثير للقلق
فعليا وانه وارد خلينا نسمع هذه الجزئيه
من لسان من نفسه
[موسيقى]
المنصات العراقيه والسبب مقطع فيديو منتشر
بشكل كبير لمدرس بهين الطالبات
رسل طالب
عاديه
ان شاء الله
رقم اثنين عائشه عدي
ليش
الورقه يلا طلعي
اليوم
[موسيقى]
مع انتشار المقطع بدات المعلومات تطلع
وتضح انه متصور في احد المعاهد الخاصه
وانه اللي ظاهر في المقطع مدرس كيمياء
قالوا ناس انه اسمه حسين الهاشمي والفيديو
صورته خلص احدى الطالبات الفيديو انتشر من
هنا وانفجر الناس من هنا انتقادات
ومطالبات بمحاسبه الاستاذ اللي شايفين انه
اهان الطالبات من غير وجه حق وصاروا يدعوا
الاحترام الرساله التعليميه
موضوع ان المعهد خاص زاد من غضب الناس
اللي شافت انه يعني هدول الطالبات اهاليهم
تفعيل فلوس عشان دروس خصوصيه يتعلموا فيها
مو علشان ينهانوا وفي اخرين شافوا انه
معهد خاص او حكومه الموضوع مرفوض وسيء في
كلتا الحالتين طبعا عموما امام حاله الغضب
هذه تحلت او تحركت السلطات فعلا ووزير
التربيه امر بتشكيل لجنه تحقيق عاجله حول
المقطع ووصفوا بانه في تعامل بطريقه بعيده
عن السمات التربويه مكتب الوزير امها
للجنه التحقيقيه 48 ساعه لتعلن نتائج
تحقيقها واكد انه ما بيسمح لاحد بالمساس
بالطلبه مهما كانت الاسباب والتصرف معاهم
بطريقه هوجه واكد الوزير على قدسيه مهنه
التعليم ورسالتها الانسانيه والاخلاقيه
وانه اللي متورط بافعال من هذه لا يستحق
الصفه التربويه اللي بيحملها وامر الوزير
كمان باغلاق المعاهد اللي بتخالف قوانين
الوزاره ومبادئ الشرف المهنه التعليميه
اهلا من جديد غدا ولمصممه جرافيكس مصريه
عالميه سبق واختارتها ضمن قائمه تضم اهم
30 فنان تحت سنه 30 في 2017 وجمعيه الفن
المطبعي في شيكاغو اختارتها من افضل 100
مصمم جرافيك في العالم ولها اعمال عن عرضت
حول العالم مشاركه في مسابقات عالميه كمان
ومعروفه محليه جدا كمان غاده معها ماجستير
في التصميم ومعروفه باعمالها لكن من فتره
سمعنا باسمها وسط ازمه اتهامات سرقه من
فنان روسي واليوم نفس الفنان اتهمها من
جديد وبخصوص اعمال ثانيا فاللي صاير انه
فنان روسي اسمه جورجي كورسوف طلع واتهم
غاده بان سرقت تصميمات لو الكلام طلع على
لسان محامي الفنان وبيقول المحامي انه
الفنان كورسوف اكتشف انه احد لوحاته
ورسوماته استخدمت في اعلان
صممته غاده وقال انه ماشي في اجراءات
مقاضات الشركه وغاده وانه كمان بيطالب باع
وتعويض مادي ضخم لكن لازم نقول هنا ان
المحامي والفنان ما طلعوا مستندات ولا صور
ولا ادله يعني ما طلعوا شيء يثبت كلامهم
وقالوا بس انهم راح يقدموا هذه الادله
اللي عندهم هي للقضاء الموضوع ملفت لانه
نفس هذا الفنان من شهور اتهم غاضب انها
سرقت لوحات من اعماله في تصاميم الجداريات
على محطه مترو كليه البنات في القاهره
ووقت الموضوع كبير جدا وانتهى الموضوع
باعتذار الهيئه القوميه للانفاق من الفنان
والجمهور وازاله الجداريه نرجع للازمه
اللي صايره الان الاعلان اللي بيتكلم عنه
الفنان الروسي هي التصاميم اللي شايفينها
امامكم لهذه الكنز احنا تواصلنا مع غاده
اللي بتنفي طبعا كل كلام الفنان الروسي
وبتاكد انه هي كمان راح تلجا للقضاء
المصري وبتثق فيه عدالته غاده زودتنا
بالصور اللي شايفينها امامكم الان واللي
قالت انها من الاسكتشات الخاصه فيها
للتصاميم اللي كانت على
العلب
غاده كمان خصصنا بفيديو حصري من كمبيوتر
هذا الشخصي بيثبت تصميمها بنفسها للحمله
الاعلانيه
وغير الصور والفيديو اللي شفناه غاداء
ولحبه من خلال تفاعلكم ترد بالصوت والصوره
ولاول مره على الاتهامات الموجهه لها
مساء الخير دي اول مره اطلع اتكلم فيها في
حياتي انا السنه اللي فاتت اتعرضت الازمه
كبيره جدا اعلاميه
وساعتها انا كنت بولد وحصري مشاكل في
الولاده وكنت في المستشفى فما كانش عندي
فرصه ارد بكل قوتي بس المره دي انا هرد
انا زي اي حد اي بني ادم اتعرض لتنمر
الكتروني بالشكل الكبير جدا ده تقصر نفسيا
ومهنيا لمده السنه اللي فاتت دي كلها وده
بيحصل لي تاني دلوقتي فده بالنسبه لي
كابوس همم مش قادره اشوفه تاني بيحصل من
غير ما اعرف اتكلم وادافع عن نفسي ادم من
ساعه ما رجعت من ايطاليا بعد ما خلصت
الماجستير بتاعي
كل هدفي في الحياه اني ازاي اخلي التصميم
يحيي التراث المصري
فده مش اول مشروع اعمله بيتكلم عن نفس
الفكره دي ولا ثاني ولا ثالث ولا رابع مش
اي حد ممكن يقول اي اتهام نصدقه من غير ما
يكون في اي دلائل
الحمله بتاعه شركه المياه الغازيه دي
اتعملت في سنه 2018 وانا رسمت الرسومات دي
بايديا موجوده على النت ممكن تشوفوها
ودي كان اول مره الشركه دي تقتبس من فنان
مصري ما تاخدش مثلا التصميم من الاوفيس
بتاعهم في نيويورك او في بتاعتهم ومن كتر
ما الحمله دي كانت ناجحه الشركه طلبت مني
اني اعمل مسابقه في كليه فنون تطبيقيه مع
الطلاب
بنفس الفكره ان ازاي اختاروا تصميم ويحيا
وتصميم مصري هما بيحبوه وده احلى حاجه
شفتها في حياتي لانه فعلا الهدفي كان
بيتحقق طلاب كانت مبسوطه قوي حسوا بانتماء
لتاريخنا وتصميمنا الملهمه الجميله اللي
مش محتاجين نقلد حاجه او نوصل لحاجه بره
عشان نحس بها
انا طبعا بحترم كل الفنانين جوه او بره
مصر
وبحترم القانون المصري والقضاء المصري
لانه قضاء عادل فانا عشان كده هالجا
القضاء ده واي حد عنده مشكله ثانيه ممكن
يلجا للقضاء المصري برضه لان انا تعبت جدا
في ال 15 سنه من كريدي شركتي تعبت جدا في
فريق عملي ااا وتعبت برده عشان اوصل لصقه
عميري اداني مشروع كبير ومهم زي ده
انا مش هسيب حقي وبحترم شغلي اللي فات
واللي جاي شكرا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لختم حلقه اليوم انا
اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في اجمل
حلقات الاسبوع واجمل ايام الاسبوع الخميس
الونيس في امان الله
[موسيقى]